this week we're talking about the auto
ml tables SDK the new kubernetes
benchmark and anthos training
I'm Colt McAnlis and welcome to this
week in cloud where we serve you the
lowest latency news google cloud auto ml
offers tools and resources to help you
build the machine learning models that
you need and now the auto ml tables SDK
brings those tools to your own
application by triggering or automating
each step of the process check out this
example which shows how to use the SDK
and end within a Jupiter notebook the
Center for Internet Security provides a
set of kubernetes security best
practices with their kubernetes
benchmark and the latest version was
just released so we've released a new
CIS google kubernetes engine benchmark
to take the guesswork out of which
recommendations you should check out and
which ones we've already checked out for
you
and when it comes to keeping you covered
we know that customers rely on Google
Cloud support to be seamless simple and
straightforward
so we're adding a new proactive option
to our lineup Premium support offers
context-aware
experts that understand your
architecture and work hand-in-hand with
your technical Account Manager to solve
your problems anthos is Google clouds
open application modernization platform
and can help your apps become more
portable maintainable scalable and
secure we've just released a new
learning specialization designed for
infrastructure operators architects and
DevOps called architecting hybrid cloud
infrastructure with anthos give it a try
let us know what you think if you want
to read more about these announcements
or see the full list check out the links
in the description and below any
thoughts or ideas leave us a comment or
send us a tweet and we'll see you in the
cloud
you